[Music] Gram's glass is very soft, isn't it? The reason is that the glass that goes to the tip of the iron of the iron cat is attached, but the software is attached and the sleeves are turned in
one hand
.  It falls
and flows due to gravity, so I'm going to make it into a shape while warming it up to 5 schools.
I'm Mishima, a glass artist
[Music]
web cas japanese rs two weeks einen
onodera tendon Head  pou dou dou
plume as series 5 minutes creations Wicks as Making
For Marker Winds Pink
worth I was looking for a chance about 30 years ago,
but I couldn't find the one-wheeled one, so
my friend  However, at that time, my friends sprouted
and I started to go through the offense and defense of the village,
and now I am working as a glass writer
.
to do Four Seasons John
Do you do for swing breno glass speed pro 5
ex pen wato barbie Two-way pizza burger king cat
I think I can do more than I
expected. There are many things that are inspired by Nature 6, and I'm always walking here in
Venice, so I think I'm influenced by the reflection of water.
Personally speaking,
there is a place like a country I like, and when I see what is reflected, I feel that it is beautiful.
[Music] Since the
concept is a spear, the outline of the light is that.
After all, I want it to be a time to look at the person who sees it, such as the window of the heart when it is packed like this
[Music]